oh boy it's time all right be sure to be
super careful about here suck it Rafe
and the salts gonna drop ha ha yeah this
is the money shot all right
ha ha look at that get all the way
stupid bar hello and welcome to the
second annual your your nice awards her
queer contractual you're not supposed to
say it out Rayna thank you and yesterday
we have a very special guest with us
live in the Khalifah oh yeah who's
kissing hi all right three two one let's
jam
[Music]
Wow what can I say let's hear it for the
band everyone give yourselves a pat on
the back what a terrific crowd and now
to present the award for best film
please welcome my Luna DreamWorks the
bus baby introducing resident chill Jeff
food sensing best score and the winner
is crunchyroll.com slash basement
[Music]
[Music]
ah oh [ __ ] we must be following him
alright guys I think it's time to get
the real show started by hero academia
my hero academia my hero academia or
academia come on guys people are gonna
start saying this is rigs towards hero
academia see don't worry though never
happen and the winner for the best
continuing series is March comes there
like a line
[Music]
achievement award
please welcome Christopher sebat as your
childhood thank you thank you yes I did
indeed play all mites from my hero
academia
please welcome best comedy and best
slice-of-life presenters gugak and lily
Pichu
every Munga sensei
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sometimes we all just need to relax
and that's really Celeste enemies
mundane magic positively sparkles
watching lovable characters
[Music]
and now please welcome back the band's
as a player some more absolutely classic
tunes
please give a howling welcome to super
eyepatch wall thank you the most
powerful thing a piece of art can do is
communicate emotion and so it's natural
we want to celebrate the anime that
attempts to reflect there please can you
shut the [ __ ] up and on the final
stretch let's hear it for some more my
hero academia award comes the winner for
best hero is my boy Zuko Deku midoriya
[Applause]
as we approach your final stretch here
our key is taking the lead with no
competitors inside and as we cross the
finish line it looks like maybe the
business taking anime of the year the
crowd are going wild this is a massive
observation yet to be seen in the
history of anime round of applause for
mein in abyss
all right so serious reflection time in
his second year crunchyroll have managed
to make a big improvement to their
awards though that bar was set pretty
low last year I've seen a lot of people
complaining about how my hero academia
swept everything and honestly yes still
way to skew towards popular vote and it
would have been cool if other shows got
recognition but we all predicted this
would happen because Hiroaki is a
genuinely amazing show that happens to
also be popular and there were only a
few categories I truly think it didn't
deserve unlike last year when you'd look
at the winners and you were just like
what the new system with judges made a
small difference with some nice
surprises slipping through like girls
last tour winning best slice of life and
it showed where it really mattered
because when maiden abyss won best anime
of the year you have no idea how much
backstage erupted of course the biggest
difference this year is that we had a
live show which overall was fun but
somewhat clumsy in execution with some
awkward moments in it and this is
absolutely no disrespect to anyone
involved because I know how much work
was put into this and also I was one of
those people I mean [ __ ] we got bloody
awkward I am I find this hard to watch
back because oh good I just cringe so
bad and I was just so [ __ ] nervous
but that's kind of the beauty of it
we're not Hollywood stars we're a bunch
of awkward anime fans most of us
starting off in our bedrooms and here we
were being part of an official award
show for animate it was a somewhat
surreal experience and I think my boy
super eyepatch wolf summed up the best
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] look at this see kids
you talk about you hack a show [ __ ]
long enough eventually you'll end up in
the Hollywood Hills and clums the
execution with technical difficulties or
not I have to give huge credit to
crunchyroll for actually making it
happen I'm pretty sure this point no one
really cares about award shows or the
results because it isn't gonna change
any opinions but what it is is a
celebration of our medium and event for
us to gather around to live reacts to
get hype and really really salty over to
ever because that's something I felt has
been sorely missing from this community
when others have it in spades there is
still a lot of room for improvement the
judging a nomination system could still
be refined the categories themselves I
feel could use with a romance and a
fantasy adventure genre so Magus Frey
can actually win categories it deserves
and it would be cool if we could get to
the point where people are actually
accepting Awards because seeing Chris
sebacic Septon speech was a nice touch
and I wish there was more of it but
after everything was said and done it
felt like an achievement had been ticked
off with his community I felt proud
their medium had gone this far in the
West salt fest to know and this was a
nice first step so huge props to
everyone who made this happen thank you
for letting me take part because
regardless of the results it was just a
very fun event and I'm very much looking
forward to seeing how much this grows in
the future because you know what we all
know the real reason we wanted a live
award show for anime so we could meme
the ever-loving [ __ ] out of it
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month to Basel
Patrick Madsen Jared Cattell Vince and
Moony now Ken and everyone else in
patreon for helping to support me and
making this video possible sorry this
video was a bit late having to travel
with 20 hours after the awards plus
recover from that jetlag meant it's a
few days late but hope is worth it
regardless to anyone who i memed in this
video I am so sorry especially after I
met so many awesome people in the
weekends anyway that's it for me I've
been gig ugh and I will see you all next
time